andrey andri andrey starts working on
his science project at four o'clock p.m
and he finishes 50 minutes later
which number line below has a red dot
marking when andrew finishes working on
his science project
so they tell us that he starts his
science project at four o'clock p.m this
first shot this first choice over here
puts the dot at four o'clock but they
didn't say when did he start working on
a science project they say put a red dot
marking when andrew finishes working on
his science project so he started at
four and it says he finishes 50 minutes
50 minutes later so if you start at four
he's gonna if you add 50 minutes to 4
that's going to put us at 450. so where
is 450 on this number line so let's see
so we're on this timeline i guess i
could say so let's see this is 4 15.
so each of these marks must be 5 minutes
this is
410 415 420 425
430 435 440 445 and then 450 would be
right over here so which of these
choices has a dot at 450
this last choice has a dot has the red
dot at 450. notice this is 50 minutes
after he started at four o'clock
let's do a few more of these
amira starts raking leaves at 2 30 pm
and she finishes 25 minutes later
which number line below has a red dark a
dread dot marking when amira finishes
raking the leaves so she starts at 2 30
and she finishes 25 minutes later so it
looks like on this one each of these
each of these spaces is five minutes so
this is 2 30 so 2 30 so this is 5 10
15 20
25 minutes later and this place right
over here is 255 and see it looks like
this first choice
is actually the choice we're looking for
they put the red dot 25 minutes after 2
30. notice this is 2 30 5 minutes after
2 30 10 minutes after 2 30
15 minutes after 2 30
20 minutes after 2 30 25 minutes
after 2 30. let's keep going this is
actually a lot of fun
so the number line shows when scarlett
starts and finishes art club all right
that's when she starts that's when she
finishes
what time did scarlet start art club
well let's see this is halfway between 3
o'clock and 3 30. so that's going to be
3 15. each of these marks go up by 15
minutes so this is at 3
15.
what time did scarlett finish art club
so this is right in between 4 30 and 5
o'clock or you could say it's 15 minutes
more than 4 30 so that's going to be 4
how long was scarlett in art club
so let's think about it there's a couple
of ways you could do it you could look
at the line let's see so this to go from
this point to this point that's 15
minutes then 30 then 45 then one hour 1
hour 15 minutes 1 hour 30 minutes so you
could say 1 hour 30 minutes or actually
they want it all in minutes so one hour
is 60 minutes plus 30 minutes is 90
minutes so actually let me just do it
all in minutes again
so this is as i move my mouse this is
i'm going to talk about how many minutes
i'm adding relative to this or from the
start so 15 minutes guess it's at 3 30
30 minutes
45 minutes
60 minutes
75 minutes
90 minutes
so that's 90 minutes right over there
another way to think about it is it
would take 45 minutes to go from 3 15 to
4 o'clock
45 minutes to go from 3 15 to 4 o'clock
that makes sense and then another 45
minutes to go from 4 o'clock to 4 45
so 45 plus 45 is going to be 90 minutes
let's do
let's do a couple of these so the number
line shows when anna starts and finishes
reading a chapter in her book
what time did anna start reading so it
says right over there she started
reading at 8 10 pm
10 p.m
what time did anna finish reading let's
see let me make sure i'm reading this so
this is 8 20 this is 8 25 and they have
one two three four five marks so each of
these go up a minute so you could say
it's a minute before 8 25 or 4 minutes
after 8 24 8 21 8 22 8 23 8 24
how long did anna read well she start
shooting at 8 10 and finishes reading at
8 24 to go from 10 to 24 that means she
read for 14 minutes
and you could even count it over here 1
2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13
14.
let's do one more
muhammad speaks on the phone for 15
minutes and finishes his phone call at 9
20 am
which number line below has a green dot
marking when muhammad starts his phone
call all right it finishes at 9 20. so
it finishes let's see where's 9 20 on
this number line so it looks like each
of these marks go up by 5 minutes so
this is 9 15 and i was able to figure
that out because we have three marks
that go to 9 15 from 9 to 9 15. so this
is 905 9 10 9 15.
so this would be 9 20. so this is when
he finishes 9 20 and he was on the phone
for 15 minutes
so and remember we don't want to mark
where he finished they tell us that it's
9 20. we want to mark when he started
so if he's on a phone call for 15
minutes and he finishes at 9 20 he's
going to finish 15 minutes or sorry if
he's on the phone for 15 minutes and he
finishes at 9 20 he's going to start 15
minutes before 9 20. so 5 10 15. he's
going to start at 905.
so that's this choice right over here
another way you could think about is
look if i'm at 9 20 and i go
15 minutes before 9 20. 20 minus 15 is 5
so that's going to get me to 905.
and we could just make sure we feel good
about it if he starts his phone call at
5th at 905 and he speaks for 15 minutes
5 10 15 he's going to finish his phone
call right over here at 9 20 which is
exactly what they described